what do we know about this alleged
attack um apparently uh
reports of a drone people with breathing
issues and dizziness
so nothing more than you're reporting
i'm afraid we know that
there are reports of the use of chemical
weapons
we have not been able to verify those
ourselves and indeed the ukrainian
system
as you've seen from president zielinski
are only referring to the fact that
there are reports they themselves
haven't yet been able to confirm to us
that they have been used
the u.s president joe biden said on the
24th of last month that if chemical
attack chemical weapons were used
in ukraine that that was a red line
if it's proven what happens next
well that's exactly right i mean these
are uh appalling weapons to even think
about using and the fact that they are
part of the discussion is deeply
sobering it's not just the presence of
the united states the president of
france and our own prime minister have
also been clear that there are
weapons that simply should not be used
and if they are used people will be held
to account i think it's useful to
maintain some ambiguity k over exactly
what the response would be
but let's be clear if they are used
at all
then president putin should know that
all possible options are on the table in
terms of how the west might respond
could could we go as far as to say a
considered but effective response
well i it would certainly be effective
but it would also be well considered i
think it's a very good way of putting it
but it's important
to
recognize that there are all sorts of
ways in which
these things could be used
from the use of tear gas which is
effectively a right control measure all
the way through to
utterly devastating lethal
chemical weapon systems so i don't i
don't think it's helpful to be too
binary about the situation because these
are highly nuanced but i also think it's
very important to be very clear
with your viewers who i think have a
deep sense of what is right and what is
wrong that there are some things that
are beyond the pale and the use of
chemical weapons will get a response and
all options are on the table for what
that response could be
as a military man i know that you will
have a view on this the 36th naval
infantry brigade have been doing their
best to try to protect the people of
mario paul and to hold the line
for 47 days now
um they have commented
on
their facebook page to say that they are
running out of ammunition
and there is little else that they can
do um a thought for them
just
amazing heroism um within my
within my regiment the rifles one of the
things that um we celebrate the most was
what happened in the battle of calais
which was sort of
to hold calais whilst the dunkirk
evacuations were were going on and i i
when i read the stuff from uh the
marines and mario paul last night i was
kind of reminded of just that the
extraordinary courage that it takes to
just keep fighting as ammunition runs
low and you know that your chances of
resupply are limited and yet your sort
of sense of patriotism your sense of
duty to your country your knowledge that
the longer you fight the longer you hold
out the more opportunity it gives others
to be ready for what comes next i just
think they're amazing people and they
epitomize everything that we've come to
admire about the ukrainian armed forces
over the last six weeks uh lord richard
dannett uh former head of the british
army who i'm guessing you would have
served under during your time uh in the
military says that russia is on the
brink of genocide in ukraine what are
your thoughts i i think that we have
seen
the most appalling images brought to us
over the last few weeks as russia you
know this there's something
it's great to see debs haynes back in
kiev
it's great to see that keeve is coming
back to some sort of
normality
but as we saw those troops withdrawal
last week from booker and hoster melon
urpin the pictures we saw were just
appalling and yet those are the places
that we've been able to get cameras into
what is what it must look like how many
dead there must be
in the cities and towns that have been
under siege for the last six weeks and
we haven't yet been able to get cameras
into it is just the most monstrous loss
of life that is a deliberate tactic used
by the russians to besiege cities and
impose costs on the civilian population
that has remained um you know lord
danette used
the word genocide i would just say that
whatever is going on in ukraine from the
russians is extraordinarily bleak
and i think that the resolve of the
ukrainian people and president zielinski
to keep fighting and to win back their
territory
is amazing the cost is enormous putin
however will be held to account and so
too will everybody who serves these
governments in the chain of command who
have been responsible for these
atrocities
talk to me about imran khan
if you would please uh domestic politics
um he's been convicted of um
a sexual act against a child
um
should he resign
well i mean look he has been convicted
uh that's happened in a court of la in a
court of law so it's a judgment that of
course we respect he has had the whip
removed and has been uh expelled from
the conservative party the way that
parliament works is that you are elected
as an individual so his seat in the
house of commons um is his until he
personally chooses to vacate it there
are mechanisms now through uh recall
petitions that have been in place uh
since i think 2015 from from memory
so
if he chooses not to there are now
mechanisms through which he can uh be
removed from his seat and subjected to a
by-election i understand he has plans to
appeal but quite frankly um everybody in
government respects that a court of law
has found him guilty uh and that must be
the judgment until he appeals
successfully well crispin blunt doesn't
does he i mean he's a tory mp he's cr
he's um literally uh talks about how his
friend
is innocent he describes it as a
dreadful miscarriage of justice and
nothing short of an international
scandal does the government
distance themselves from the comments of
one of their own
yes
that's fairly straightforward do you
expect him to retract it
i don't know because i have no idea what
it is that crispin is referring to in
the comments that he said all i know is
that in a court of law yesterday
mr khan was found guilty
and i think every one of us who believes
in the judicial system and the rule of
law uh has to respect that judgment and
i think it's for crispin to account for
his words but it's not something the
government associates itself with um
should he keep the whip
again i think that it's for people to
look at today as they speak to crisp and
find out what this is all about but um
but what matters is that absolutely
nobody in her majesty's government is
seeking to be critical of the decision
of the court uh if mr khan chooses to
appeal that is for him but a course of
law has found him guilty and that is
what the government believes him to be
there for yeah and you would be content
if mr khan decided that the best course
of action was for him to resign
triggering a by-election
well i think that that is a judgment for
him but as i've said there are now
parliamentary mechanisms to ensure that
people who have been found guilty of
crimes that require a prison sentence
and in fact actually through the recall
position
those who haven't required to go to
prison but have been found guilty
of a crime
can be subjected to a by-election if
that is the will of their constituents
this is ultimately however a
parliamentary process uh mr khan has
been removed from the conservative party
and had the whip removed from his uh
from him in parliament as well
it would be of no concern to
the government ever by election was
triggered in a red wall seat that was
actually won by the conservatives for
the first time in certainly in a very
long time if if ever and the
ramifications of that oh i mean i see
what you're driving at kate but i i mean
i just don't think the politics is the
most important issue here
is a very good way of putting it um i
wondered if i could ask you about rishi
sunak
are you supportive of the chancellor and
the way he and his wife's finances are
being conducted
yes i am i am i think that he has
uh
been clear about what the arrangements
are
he has recognized that
even after his reassurances people uh
still wanted some further issuance so
he's referred himself to
uh lord gait
but i think rishi is
it's pretty straightforward pretty
straight talking and he has been pretty
clear on what the circumstances are
and the fact that the labour leader
describes um his behavior
as rank hypocrisy what would be your
response to that yeah well i i don't
think it is hypocritical because i don't
think that anybody is saying that rishi
hasn't paid the tax that he is supposed
to so i just don't get
where kirstama is coming from with that
comment i also
saw some sort of comment that suggested
that because rishi has been successful
in his life before politics he's
therefore out of touch and i think that
also is ridiculous
you yourself kay i think have on
occasions challenged uh mps and
ministers about their their competence
and whether or not they uh are up to the
job well you know here we've got someone
who has demonstrably been hugely
successful in a career in finance
before entering parliament and is now
responsible for running our economy and
very obviously i want people to be
running the economy who have been very
successful in the financial industry
before coming into politics because
surely they are the best qualified with
all the necessary experience and
expertise but i would have two counters
to that if i may minister one of them
would be um he was a green card holder
so he was resident in another country
while he was deciding what the tax
liability should be for the rest of us
here in the united kingdom i wonder if
you have a thought on that first of all
well whatever the the green card
circumstances are on i have to say i'm
not
familiar with how that all works but
even if he was holding a green card
whilst doing the deciding on tax uh in
this country no one's ever suggested
that he's done anything but pay all the
tax that he is required to in the uk
that's very true but my point is that
he's resident of another country which
he was until last october when he was
the chancellor and yet nevertheless he
felt um able to offer his view and
indeed law to decide how we paid our tax
and secondly um i have a friend who is a
captain of industry who is a non-dom but
um he still chooses to pay his tax in
the uk because he says it's the right
thing to do and now i know that mr
tsunaki will come back and say uh does
do that but his wife did not until a
spotlight was shot on that and they have
subsequently decided that they will
change that is that because they are now
doing the right thing and they didn't
previously
well i certainly think they're doing the
right thing now in that i think that it
matters to the british public that
they
think that they're or that they know
that they're political leaders are
um paying their way and paying all of
the taxes that they
are due to but to be clear no one is
suggesting that rishi's wife ever
avoided paying tax she paid all the tax
that she needed to on the income she
earned in the uk she had non-domiciled
status because she is a foreign national
and she
hasn't made herself resident in the uk
for the purposes of tax and her business
she's changed that decision out of
loyalty to her husband's um political
career and there's a sort of unease if
you don't mind me saying that in 2022
that is still something that she felt
compelled to do to support her husband
but um she never did anything wrong by
being non-dom she is an indian national
and she pays her tax elsewhere she's
changed that out of loyalty to rishi uh
i think that's very admirable
perhaps all pales um when one thinks
about what's happening in mario paul at
the moment but we appreciate you taking
the time to join us on the programme
this morning minister thank you very
much indeed